hey there Tech Trailblazers are you
ready to soar above the server room and
into the poundless world of cloud
computing you are in the luck welcome
back to our Channel and today we are
unveiling an exciting opportunity that
could reshape your career path the cloud
engineer learning path Now featuring The
revamped preparing for the associate
cloud and genius certification course if
you are ready to write the cloud wave
and earn that coveted Associated Cloud
ingenious certification stick around
remember to hit that subscribe button
and tap the notification Bell so you are
always in the know and before we begin
if you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cloud computing by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who has sits to switch
careers with cloud computing by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cloud computing with certificates
aligned with AWS partner Network and
silver Microsoft partner the link is
mentioned in the description box below
below that will navigate you to the
course page and you can have a complete
overview of the program being offered
now let's Dive Right In so first we'll
see the career with Cloud associate
Cloud engineer leave the server racks
behind and Venture into the dynamic
world of cloud computing the perfect
movement has arrived and now let's talk
about what this certification means for
you your associate Cloud engineer
certification is like a bacon signaling
to prospective employers your progress
in Google Cloud as an associate Cloud
engineer you will be Adept at deploying
and securing applications and
infrastructure you will maintain
Enterprise solutions to meet performance
standards and keep a watchful eye on the
operations of multiple Cloud projects
but that's not all associate Cloud
Engineers also prove their Mastery in
using the Google Cloud console and
command line interface you will
effortlessly manage and scale Cloud
Solutions leveraging Google managed or
self-managed services on Google cloud
and many of our peers once dwelled in
the own premium Israel meticulously
setting up servers now they are prepared
to level up their skills for the cloud
era the associate Cloud engineer
certification is a stepping stone to a
flourishing I.T career so picture
yourself as a cloud developer architect
security engineer systems engineer or
network engineer the possibilities are
endless so let's get started with the
benefits of doing gcp Ace so the first
benefit you can gain by acing this
certification is you will have the
membership to Google credential holder
portal so I will show you so this is the
Google Cloud certified directory here
you can find all the people who have
played this certification and you can
just click on the LinkedIn profile and
see what skills they possess and you
have other filters also that is you can
search by the credentials locations or
skills so this is the first benefit of
doing gcp AC now moving back second
benefit is exposure to all gcp services
by while preparation will boost your
confidence and then this will set a good
foundation for professional architect
exam and Google certification and badge
to be used in your profile for
visibility that will uphold your profile
and will gain you many opportunities and
now we'll see steps what you can follow
to Ace the gcp AC certification exam so
before we dive in it's essential to
graph the exam structure the Google
associate Cloud engineer certification
exam consists of 50 multiple choice
questions and you have a total of two
hours to complete it a passing score
requires at least 70 percent correctness
this exam evaluates your knowledge of
Google Cloud platform Services basic
networking Concepts and cloud computing
fundamentals and the recommended
experience for this certification is 6
Plus months and the prerequisites are
none for this education exam and the
link to register for this exam I will
mention that link in the description box
below and I will show you the link also
so this is the link here you have to go
and make your profile if you don't have
an account and after that you can log in
so this is here where you will register
for the exam and moving back now we'll
see the step two that is getting
familiar with gcp so to succeed you need
to become best friends with Google Cloud
platform luckily Google offers a free
tire that allows you to explore gcp's
product and services without cost and
don't forget about the comprehensive gcp
documentation it's your treasure Trove
of insights into various services and
functionalities so you can just go to
the documentation and read it and the
third is enroll in a course or training
program so education is the key here
enroll in a course or training program
tailored to the Google associate Cloud
engineer exam the simply learned Caltech
cloud computing bootcamp course lets you
master key architectural principles and
develop the skills needed to become a
cloud expert and provides in-depth
coverage of exam topics or if you prefer
hands-on experience the associate Cloud
engineer exam prep Quest from Quick Labs
is a great choice and I will mention the
link for the boot camp in the
description box you can go there and you
can enroll in a course or training
program to Ace the preparation and now
the step 4 take practice test sharpen
your skills with practice test Google
Cloud offers official practice tests for
purchase which give you a real feel for
the exam environment Cloud Guru and Wiz
Labs also provide valuable practice
exams and if you are budget conscious
exam Labs offer free practice test and
now moving on to the step 5 review exam
objectives and resources so stay focused
by reviewing the exam objectives
outlined by Google Cloud these guides
serve as your roadmap to success dive
deep into Google Cloud's documentation
and white papers for additional study
materials don't forget to engage with
the Google Cloud community on Reddit for
valuable insights and tips and now
talking about the syllabus I will move
to the website directly only so this is
the syllabus
for Google Cloud architect so here you
will learn and you should know the
setting of A Cloud solution environment
for setting up organization resources
that is then you shouldn't have a
knowledge on planning and configuring a
Cloud solution deploying and
implementing a Cloud solution and
ensuring successful operation of a Cloud
solution so these all are the things
that are covered in the slavers so you
should have a hands on that as I told
you about the boot camp so all these
syllabus topics are covered in that boot
camp or the postgraduate program that I
have mentioned in the starting so if you
move into each step program you can just
enroll in the course or training program
and now moving back now we'll just have
a look at the tips to Ace this exam so
the first step is book the exam in
advance before starting preparation so
you don't miss out and the second tip is
practice practice and practice that will
help you clear that certification and
the third database start the exam with
relaxed mind and take poses after 5
questions each time that really helps
and then we have the fourth tip that is
understand intention of question look
for keywords in questions and answers
and the tip 5 while choosing options
focus on available option do not worry
about perfect answer and there you have
a tech explorers you'll gateway to a
cloud powered future awaits the cloud
engineer learning path crowned by the
revamped preparing for the associate
Cloud engineer certification course is a
compass to steer your career toward New
Horizons now let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers
and I am currently living in Algeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
live and I also realized that to get a
new job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
culted from Sample video but with this
course I had the choice to study while I
come to Japan that is how I got this new
job offer with 60 salary high in Finland
I will be leading the cloud computing
unit of my new company we cannot wait to
start our new life in Finland we are
also if you found this sneak peek
interviewing give it a thumbs up and
share it with fellow Tech Enthusiast and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more insights tutorials and career
guidance as you embark on a cloud
Journey remember to stay curious Embrace
new challenges and keep reaching for the
clouds
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and
a student and aim to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here